all right well let's let's move on to
the next story okay it's really hard to
get away from that stuff it's so big
it's so important but um I saw a clip
earlier that made me very maybe laugh a
lot it was from Steve bannon's war room
and Bannon said that Alex Jones was on
the Forefront of the transhumanism stuff
before everybody and then he shows a
clip of Alex from several years ago just
screaming that interdimensional demons
have possessed people and are sending
the message I just thought it was funny
I'm like I don't know I don't care I
mean whatever it was just it's funny to
watch and uh oh that that's I just
brought that up for no reason just to
mention that it was funny but we have
the story about Alex Jones Alex Jones
threatens to Dish dirt on a pathetic
Donald Trump for pushing vaccines and
tells his Infowars listeners to move on
from the Republican 2024 front runner
Alex Jones said Wednesday that he will
dish all the dirt on Donald Trump now
the former president has come out more
definitively in favor of vaccinations in
fact maybe you know what to get Trump's
attention maybe I should just dish all
the dirt the far-right media personality
said on Infowars Jones said the
impending gossip is not to hurt Trump
it's so people can know how pathetic he
is when you think he's playing 4D chess
Trump was booed by his supporters
earlier this month when he revealed that
he received the kova 19 booster shot but
I just want to point out Trump's always
been in favor of this Trump spearhead of
the operation warp speed campaign he's
at his rallies telling people to get it
I don't understand how this is new
information but I do think it's
interesting I'm wondering if you get
what you guys think on Alex Jones you
know what happened Trump had previously
said you know he was pro-vax but he was
against oh Trump was previously saying
that he was pro-vax but against the
boosters
um and then he said he was against the
boosters
right and then he hit a point where he's
like I got the booster so it was more um
it was he was kind of walking it back a
little bit and then it seemed as though
he kind of is now more in favor of it
well he definitely favorable at least
what I'm hearing from the Trump
supporters that I know is that he had
plausible deniability early on like he
wanted to just get out of a pandemic he
wanted to get out of lockdowns and
that's why he put in operation warp
speed into place and now that he sees it
as far insofar as I understand it he
sees the vaccine as his legacy that's
why he's at times so desperately trying
to make it his legacy but the Trump
supporters that I know are really angry
about this like I know we were talking
the other night and you said that most
of the people are just like oh you got
the booster so what but every Trump
supporter that I know they're furious at
the fact that he is still pushing it
after what they perceive to be there's
data that's come out that he should be
aware of and I don't know why he's not
aware of it didn't Trump say that it's
hard to criticize Biden now because
Biden congratulated him on the work he
did with the vaccine did he say that I
believe that I got a fact check it
really quickly but he's on the same side
of fauci fauci is also saying Donald
Trump is doing the right thing here and
singing Trump's Praises so uh when
you're on the same side as as Biden and
fauci and promoting a big Pharma out of
control unaccountable huge institution
that doesn't have any liability there
should be a lot of questions here and
what Donald Trump said wasn't backed by
science he didn't present any data he
didn't present any kind of evidence he
went off and talked in tangents and
generalizations about pushing a
narrative and agenda it was just it was
just a generic mainstream media talking
point that didn't explain anything he
said you're going to die if you don't
take this essentially yes did Trump
literally say that um his points what
did what was his words exactly like
um we've got to look up we're talking
about the Bill O'Reilly interview right
no we're talking about the Candace Owens
interview oh so there's a number of
interviews where he's he's gone off and
talked about this uh so Donald Trump has
been extremely bullish on big Pharma
extremely supportive of of you know the
Trump scene as he calls it and a lot of
people are like wait wait you know
where's the science where's the data at
least talk to us in a way where you
could convince us with information
you're not doing that you're kind of
speaking in general General platitudes
and people are like wait what's going on
here so that's the larger question
Donald Trump wants credit for this
Geraldo said call it the Trump vaccine
give him credit for this Donald Trump
will never let this go and Donald Trump
cares more about the opinion of the New
York Times than his own constituents
yeah I think that was true with the
hiring of John Bolton with the refusal
to Fire fauci and even now when when
there was an interview and they're like
why didn't you fire fauci I can't
remember where it was on I might have
been Kenneth's owns but he was just like
oh you know the left gets and people
were like are you kidding is that is
that legit
I don't I don't I don't I don't know
what's going to happen in 2024 but I'll
tell you this Donald Trump was the
Avatar of the Rage of the poppy of
populist moderates in this country and
if there's nowhere to place that rage
it's going to go wild yeah Donald Trump
specifically said eight days ago that
those who don't get the shots those
dying in the hospitals didn't get the
shot those are his exact words so
um and again there's a lot of data
there's a lot of information coming out
whether it's the New York Times Daily
Mail or even this uh latest Robert Koch
Institute report that kind of cite the
opposite of that and there's a lot of
debates surrounding that so again Mass
generalization you're going to die if
you don't get this well there's a lot of
information that's up for debate about
that what Trump said was uh oh no the
vaccine works the ones that get very
sick and go to the hospital are the ones
that don't take the vaccine so he is
definitely implying heavily that you may
end up definitely at least it's within a
paradigm right so it's within a paradigm
that you don't have if you have no if
you're in a paradigm that you have no
control over your health or your
well-being right if you're unhealthy and
you believe that there's just this
standard American diet that you can eat
and that's it that's just life then that
is a solution within that Paradigm other
people you know in the Natural Health
world this is viewed as laughable like
if you start following natural healthy
people that you know are incredibly
vibrant right and you start following
them
um just follow them on Instagram look up
the top 10 Natural Health people that
have incredible Health incredibly
vibrant I mean have you ever heard of
Wim Hof maybe yeah oh yeah it'd be
amazing if you could get them on the
show you know but people like that but
what's funny is I bet that you couldn't
even bring anybody to talk about
anything natural on the show because you
couldn't even broadcast it so I mean
there's so much it will take you down
yeah like I haven't been sick in 10
years so much as a common cold but I'm
not going to get into that you know so
so you've got to understand that like
this is a paradigm that they're in and
this is the problem with not having free
speech is that somebody could be correct
within a paradigm but then there could
be this whole other Paradigm in which
there's another way of seeing it YouTube
doesn't for nuance you know and and the
people who delete videos on social media
are typically not versed in politics and
can't tell the difference between you
know certain like issues a good example
is there was a a post on Instagram it
was a famous Pro lgbtq poem that used
slurs but it was like attacking the slur
and then attacking those who would use
it this this person who posted it got
banned and they were like this is like a
very famous poem from the 70s and
Instagram is like we don't know we don't
care then you get there there was this
one really funny thing happened when a
bunch of white feminists started posting
kill all men on on Facebook and Facebook
started Banning them all and they were
like wait why are you doing this and
it's like Facebook doesn't care they
don't care about what you're intending
to say they don't care about your Nuance
the dude in India who is working on this
on this click farm reading through the
stuff doesn't know anything about
American culture just sees words he was
told to delete and he deletes them
that's how it works exactly and many
times even including corporate media
reports that power is abused people have
been putting their own kind of
perspective their own kind of religious
ideologies when it comes to censoring
information on the internet and that has
been used because a lot of these big
tech companies Outsource it to different
countries and when different countries
have different cultural issues they
Implement those cultural issues
sometimes when it comes to the
censorship but what happened to Dr
Robert Malone is absolutely uh awful he
went on did he go on Rogan today um
according to many sources yes he did go
on Rogan and there's going to be a video
published of that there's a previous
video with of course
um not Robert Malone but there's another
doctor that just uh Joe Rogan
interviewed that McCullough those videos
were also censored on on YouTube uh when
McCullough uploaded it on his own
YouTube channel so you know there's a
famous saying when you tear out a Man's
Tongue you're not proving him a liar
you're only tell in the world that you
fear what he might say and you know what
that that comes from um no Game of
Thrones yes I thought Tyrion Lannister
yeah Peter Dinklage who said the reason
people didn't like the show is because
they wanted the the white people to get
married or something like that I don't
know I don't remember right now yeah
that was his character great if the show
had good writing before yeah
a controversial opinion I like the
ending but that's a different topic oh a
different topic I did I did I did it's
Unique it's different it's not a Disney
movie excuse me but before we get into
that before we talk about that
um again the censorship is totally out
of control and Glenn Greenwald really
had a great comment about this he says I
have a sigh of relief knowing I'm
ad-libbing here that I'm protected by um
uh College wearing flip-flop people
drinking Starbucks away from scientific
debate keeping us safe from from you
know from any kind of rational
intellectual discourse here he didn't
say it that way but he said something
yeah think about Larry King and the
people he would have on his show people
who are not prominent and people who had
despicable ideas and he would put them
on this major show show all of all the
people of the world watching you know I
was at CNN when he was doing the show
and they would be like these people are
nuts now something weird is happening
you have doctor is Peter McCullough he's
a doctor right Dr Malone and they go on
the biggest podcast in the world I'm
assuming Malone's on the podcast but
they've also been um Milan's also been
on Dark Horse with Brett Weinstein and
they talk about their opinions their
medical opinions and it gets deleted
gets removed from the conversation
there's no opportunity to challenge so
it happens those ideas find the
underground people in the underground
watch it uncritically and believe all
that sometimes they should sometimes
they shouldn't but YouTube seems to be
either either it is they care so much
more about making money so they will
delete anything remotely controversial
creating this hyperpolarization or a
form of it or they like creating the
hyperpolis polarization and there's
something nefarious behind it yeah in
the National Health world the big the
big the big frustration is that this
could have been a moment to get people
to look at health and vitality so the
Natural Health world you have people
that are not only Mass again I'm kind of
dancing around some things here but it's
like massively of just infused with
Vitality I mean if you've seen the Wim
Hoff videos of him hiking up Mount
Everest in his underwear right there's
these incredible things that you could
be doing so this could have been this
this big moment and it didn't have to be
mutually exclusive it didn't have to be
big Pharma or natural but we could have
just included that in the conversation
you could have the whole country
becoming healthier than ever and
mandating no don't mandate it but I'm
just saying there's that Meme where it's
like
um you know doctors you you can't talk
about recommending exercise proper diet
sunlight Vitamin D even though fauci
himself has brought some of this up for
the most part it's not a part of the
equation in the mainstream there's only
one solution and that solution is
vaccination my response is I mean even
fauci's talked about vitamin D and the
importance of it but then these
politicians and and fauci included want
lockdowns which put people in boxes with
no sunlight they get no vitamin D then
they get sick I don't even know if
natural necessarily even the right word
for the broader picture of just Health
just General Health I think yeah I think
he talked about vitamin D once and you
know the windhof method the windhof has
has literally broken a scientific belief
systems with some of the things he's
been able to pull off uh and as soon as
you know everything happened I remember
just doing the windhof method as soon as
covet hit I went uh got on a farm in
Pennsylvania and I just started doing uh
cold bats and breathing exercises and
it's you know personally I can't tell
you guys what to do but personally I saw
a lot of results from it and again we
should be able to have a discussion
we're not medical doctors we're not
scientists we're not here to tell you
what to do but but you know these
conversations we should be having in an
open platform and we can't even really
do that so this is why it's important to
be this is why censorship is bad and I
think everyone everyone gets this but
I'll just iterate it or reiterate it
when I call a doctor I get coven and the
doctor says it's a virus go to bed and I
was like okay
I ended up talking to Joe Rogan because
I knew he got some kind of treatment and
then he said look man find a better
doctor call somebody and then I called
another a private practice out here and
I talked to a doctor and they said I
want you to take these specific
medications
here's the problem that was a doctor
telling me what to do but Don Lemon says
not to do this so you I mean at what
point do we say oh we're going to file a
lawsuit against these companies for
intervening in proper medical care when
when Joe this is what really pisses me
off Joe Rogan comes out and he says
here's what I got someone calls their
doctor the doctor says I want you to do
this and that person says no doc I won't
because Don Lemon told me not to is is
there gonna be like a wrongful uh death
suit when when CNN makes fun of Joe
Rogan for taking horse dewormer and it
makes people not want to get medicated
my concern is that people in Africa who
need ivermectin for river blindness will
now think it's some kind of sterile
sterilizing agent because a bunch of
journalists reported that it was it's
insane so we we need to be able to have
conversations that are reasonable and
rational but the these big Tech sensors
ain't letting it happen thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this Channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time